so when should an entrepreneur start
thinking about accessibility from the
beginning immediately even just during
the product conception phase it's
critical to be thinking about this you
should be thinking about how could this
really benefit the and improve the life
of a user with or without a disability
thinking about how could my product be
used in various situations things like
that are really important I think a good
example is Google Books which was became
really beneficial to everyone in that
now all of these books that were tucked
away in libraries across the world were
digitized and you could see them just by
typing in your computer so now is it
only beneficial to you and I but folks
that use screen readers now they are
able to use these have these books read
to them be a screen reader which in the
past they would have to wait for a
Braille version and which are very
costly and time consuming to get so this
is a I think a great example of why it's
important to think of these things early
so how do you go about designing for all
users what sort of lessons learned from
Google books or maybe other digital
products should should not recruiters be
aware of and know about so I think the
first thing is to just for you and your
team members to become familiar with
with accessibility basics and most
importantly is understanding the needs
of users with disabilities so like when
you're starting out any project you want
to reach out to users that you think
will be your end user and understand
their needs their challenges their their
pain points and so this is the exact
same thing you want to do with people
with disabilities so reaching out to
folks that you feel like meet your
target audience that also have
impairments is is really important and
the insights that you gain are
invaluable the other thing you want to
do is become more familiar with
assistive technologies so assistive
technologies are tools that a number of
people use to just kind of help them
achieve the same tasks that that other
people would with just a little bit of
assistance so examples of this are
closed captioning in videos where you
can see the words being that are being
said you see those typed at the bottom
of those there
magnification devices that people with a
vision might need to use there are
screen readers which essentially read
the content of the screens to the users
so you don't have to become an expert on
these by any means because that would
take forever but just understanding the
basics as well as watching and observing
somebody use these specifically watching
them use the assistive technologies with
your product is again it's one of the
most eye-opening experiences I've ever
had and then I think another thing to
keep in mind is that there are a number
of online resources for accessibility
design guidelines that give you lots of
points of what to consider when you're
designing so an example might be when
you're in the visual design stage you
want to be thinking about good color
contrast so that users with low vision
can actually read what's on the screen
or the page when you're thinking about
interaction design you want to ensure
that again what we talked about before
where the keyboard users that only use a
keyboard are able to complete all of the
tasks that they're trying to achieve